is it just me or do all these women look
incredibly uncomfortable wrote another
in part the posters reached out to Alice
for comment oh this chick
what is her name again I covered her
before uh Drew afulo afulo I don't know
this chick
by the way when I update my first book
the chapter on red flags under this
segment uh number 10 red flag number 10
with tattoos and piercings we're going
to be adding crazy ass fingernails and
I'm going to describe why when I do the
revised version in that chapter this
chick is a total train wreck tattoos on
the hand long ass fingernails loud
annoying disagreeable she's just one of
those disgusting people that just picks
up on everything it just has it has one
of the most outrageous raunchy
statements and clearly doesn't like
dudes anyway let's check content creator
popular for online takedowns of
controversial controversial men's
responded to clips of whatever podcast
and Tick Tock and what is she what does
she say
F this podcast for real if you will set
in one clip does this open into her clip
no just a picture anyway content creator
who counts eight million thanks for
zingy clapbacks of misogynistic man it's
it's completely okay when you get these
loud disgusting women like this
um that have opinions about men
for that to go viral and to celebrate
that but if a man on a podcast is asking
a very average only fans girl uh a
question like you know how many guys
have you been with in the past then that
is totally unacceptable right I mean we
can have one withdrew but we can't have
the other with Brian
but again we're not dealing with
society's best you know like this chick
over here not society's best a lot of
the panelists that they select for these
podcast shows not society's best there's
better women out there but they wouldn't
make for good shows would they
in one clip a fuelo stitches a snippet
of Atlas calling a female panelist not a
10 in reference to Rolex in which he
says that's just your opinion let's see
if this will open and play
okay
all right so that did open and it will
play for me so let's watch this together
to see what they're talking about here
uh
so the caption is laughing in their face
is much more effective I promise
and here's a clip over here
and let's play this
hey so you think you're Italian
yeah
I think I'm gorgeous I think I'm perfect
listen don't take this the wrong way it
on me you're you're not no look In
fairness I don't think Brian is being
unreasonable
she stated what she thinks her value is
on the marketplace and he's just feeding
back saying I don't want to be mean here
but I don't think you are
let's keep going another 10. okay that's
just your opinion all right first of all
every time I feel like we I forgot about
this chick's laugh
I'm gonna have to apologize to my
audience in advance because you're going
to have to tolerate the sound of Drew
laughing it's like do you remember in
class when a kid would go to the
chalkboard maybe I'm dating myself
because probably chalkboards don't exist
in schools anymore but they would scrape
their nails in the chalkboard this is
what we're gonna I'm sorry guys but just
to get to the point on this
Stamp Out a roach AKA a white man with a
podcast like this
nothing other than
our new and inventive two more replace
it like you [__] are multiplying like
bunnies huh but I digress you know what
I mean this clip literally proves what
I've said over and over and over again
this man is looking in her eyes and
telling her no offense you're not a 10.
she's going that doesn't offend me
that's just your opinion and there's
this like pause where he's like
did you hear me I just called you ugly
she goes again just your opinion it
doesn't bother her that this [__]
[__] who looks like he sells Bibles for
a living thinks she's ugly but at home
attacks immediately right this effing
bee that looks like he sells Bibles for
a living and he literally didn't say you
look ugly that's not what he said he
just responded
in what appears to me anyway as an
outsider viewing it in relative kindness
just putting it out there just trying to
be honest with you but you're not a 10.
that's all I heard others him that it
doesn't bother her he like continues to
try to antagonize her I'm not gonna
reach you listen I'm not gonna reach you
but if I were if I were gonna rate you
it's not a 10 this [__] doesn't [__]
care not even a little bit and that's
how you all should be you know why
because social currency with men is
[__] worthless [__] look at this man
he could be 48 or 21. if I were to seek
counsel on the opinions of good luck why
the [__] would I ask the general manager
of State Farm [__] like why would I ask
him I wouldn't see that's the T men hate
nothing more than when you don't give a
[__] what they think about you
especially when it comes to looks same
thing goes for when they call you fat
you say that to me all the goddamn time
first of all if that's not an insult
second of all I think that too if I
still had to sit in a car seat you know
what I mean
our response to that is send me a
picture of you I love to talk about what
other people look like I'll do it for
free [__] there are opinions of me
especially and my looks are worth
nothing more than white dog [__] [__]
instead of going on God forsaken
podcasts like this one I want to crawl
back in that sewer [__] those kids
aren't gonna eat themselves bye
all right well that's the reference that
uh the author of the article the
journalist uh linked so let's go back to
her article and continue on
because
she's pretty disgusting to be honest
with you anyway a fool of Stitch is a
snippet of Atlas calling female panels
not a 10 in reference to relooking which
she says that's just your opinion
imagine using a willow as a point of
reference
this
is the point of reference that she's
using in her argument
not much better than some of the
panelists on these shows to be honest
with you uh let's just opinion in
response Atlas continues to reiterate
his stance on her attractiveness because
it bothers him that it doesn't bother
her
and like again like this goes back to
the point of these a lot of these
podcasts are trying to hold women
accountable
like you're not a 10 but I'm a 10. well
that's your opinion but I'm a 10. well
in all honesty you're not a 10. no but
I'm a 10. she's not going to change her
opinion of herself the creators of
podcasts sending these women down must
know by now that they're not going to
change their opinion of themselves it's
just to spark interest like when I was
younger we had TV shows like Maury
Povich Jerry Springer again I'm dating
myself but it seems like a lot of these
podcasts and the panels that are put
together and the topics that they talk
about like I'm just waiting for a
podcast that comes up on the Internet
with with panelists where it's like and
you are the father or and you're not the
father and everybody erupts and there's
a fight on stage and bouncers have to
come in and pull them apart like they
did on the Jerry Springer Show it's
it's like one or two steps away from
that if we're being honest like this is
the direction that it's going anyway uh
Snippets just your opinion in response
Atlas continues to radio his stance okay
fine and another a foolo responds to a
video of the whatever podcast featuring
atlas's claims that men are more pressed
than women why people why people
continue to go on this podcast I just
can't even begin to understand I'll tell
you why they go the panelists go on for
the attention
um these are girls that are looking to
you know broadcast themselves and
they'll run uh maybe an only fans and
have a social media presence on
Instagram or on Twitter they'll post
some teases about who they are and I
mean they got to be getting business
because
from a business perspective
if you keep going back and doing
something over and over again there's
got to be an Roi like I know for a fact
whenever I would have run ads in the
past on my debt business I would usually
use social media sometimes pay-per-click
ads but even like Facebook ads you know
for example when I ran those like 10 15
years ago
um we would continue to reinvest in
placements that paid off and we would
pull back on placements that didn't have
a return on investment but these girls
they keep going back on the show so to
pretend like they are not getting
something out of it I think that's
disingenuous and whoever this journalist
is has not done the research again I
think a lot of mainstream media and I
don't know if the New York Post would be
considered mainstream media but a lot of
these journalists today they're just
sloppy right
um we saw what happened when the BBC
tried to interrogate Tate my
understanding is uh pbd and saucenick
were just there recently from what I saw
on social media so that'll be an awesome
interview looking forward to getting
some real perspective versus uh hit
pieces but you know this is what you get
with journalism today and pieces like
this
um you know there's there's a lot of
there's a lot of pieces to this puzzle
if I can put it that way
um F this podcast for real another
picture of the panel is here whatever
isn't the first podcast of It's kind to
ignite frenzy Fury online or his vice
put it the fuel sorry fuel the gender
culture World War
there's been a look
there's been a celt a culture War long
before uh dating podcasts ended up on
the internet on video platforms on
YouTube on rumble or wherever it is they
happen to broadcast it's called toxic
feminism and the gender War has started
a long time ago decades ago and it is
not about equality it's not about
improving you know the lives of women at
this point it's about the subjugation
and servitude of men right they want
guys to basically bend the knee
apologize for things that they have
never done except accusations for
um
anything you know at this point without
proof now even going back 10 20 years
you know in some cases I'm surprised
somebody hasn't accused Jesus of doing
something wrong you know like in a
hashtag me too at this point but it's
been going on for a long time and I
think all that's really happened is you
know some of these podcasters have
figured out well we'll get a table a
bunch of mics some bratty entitled girls
will serve them some booze you guys see
these cups here
these are these are mostly not water if
you watch these shows in the way these
women behave especially in Long format
when you get to the other Clips you know
deeper down the rabbit hole a lot of
them are inebriated and I don't know if
it's alcohol or if it's weed or or what
they're on but it looks like a good
portion of them that are on the show are
offside
the interesting thing about that is
isn't alcohol the most honest truth
teller that exists out there it just
removes filters if somebody's an
absolute and complete [__] then
getting them drunk will make them an
even more absolute incomplete [__] if
they're an entitled brat they'll become
even more of an entitled brat and I
think this is when you see a lot of
these guests you know thrown off the
show or uh Frank castled or whatever
they're you know they're calling it but
this is you know this is part of the
play
it's it's a simple recipe
find entitle bratty women that have a
strong opinion of themselves that's well
beyond what their SMB would be in the
real world ideally that have a high
Notch count ideally that do things
online like uh only fans you know for
example or maybe cam work or whatever it
happens to be but they have a reason to
be there so that they can you know
hashtag you know follow me wherever uh
let them drink you know if it's
available it seems and when they get out
of hand throw them off the set
boom
anybody can do that you guys right now
if you want to do that can set up your
own podcast and do the exact same thing
Tick Tock and Twitter flutter with
Snippets of talk shows men in their
living rooms with microphones
is that what they call this let me just
click that and see where that takes me
oh we're
back to Drew faguelo let's see what she
has to say so this one takes me to
a man gadsy uh that's interesting
because he seems to be one of the safer
guys so let's see why they hyperlink
this
anyway this is back in the lab so this
is this uh mouthpiece here let's see
what she's going to say here uh we'll
speed it up a little bit we got volume
and play we were born nothing and no one
will ever do anything for you as a woman
because we're basically all the
feminists are non-attractive women who
are like yeah but I don't get anything
it's like well yeah okay you also don't
go to the gym ever
profound I remember this guy I [__] up
your friend Right the dude sitting
across on you that has a taint for lips
yeah I remember the two you I also
remember the two of you saying that that
clip was taken out of context after I
E30 your [__] video right shocker I
was right about the two of you being the
worst this video was a train wreck from
start to finish first up when you're
saying as a man you're born with
literally nothing I'd argue that anyone
regardless gender is born with nothing
like that's pretty standard for all
babies you know you're acting like
you're a [__] sea turtle like your
mom hatched you on the beach and then
was like I'm [__] Deuces figure it
out what are you a deer I love the drag
towards fat women for literally no
reason at all I'm also born without
anything cool have you tried going to a
[__] gym fatty Sound Logic brother
even go on to Spin A Yarn can you hear
that the world's tiniest [__] violin
how not only is it not hard being a
woman but that you yourself have no
privilege whatsoever and there's been a
targeted attack on all men when it comes
to that last thing happy next time you
know what I mean but I'm not even going
to get into the nuances of privilege
because based off the h m fit I can tell
that brain is [__] void of all and
any intersectionality whatsoever but I
will say this admitting that you have
privileges in this life does not mean
that you've never struggled it means
there's not also invisible barriers that
prevent you from succeeding and living a
happy and fulfilled life in an extremely
bigoted world run by says head Whiteman
but we're gonna water it down completely
because also based off the cut that's as
far as the brain can go get lined up
[__] you're over complicating things no
one's telling you to apologize for being
a man they're telling me to tell
apologize for being insufferable which
clearly you're very unaware of instead
of crying to the internet about how
unfair it is that women are treated
better than you maybe worry about the
fact that you look like the world's
worst fancy Football manager you look
like you follow those inspirational
businessmen accounts on Instagram you
look like you wear a fedora on vacation
and you also look like you think your
hands are really attractive you have
other more important things to worry
about is my [__] point [__] or to
avoid all of this you just [__] off you
know bye
so I mean where do I even start with
that I'm I'm really surprised that that
is linked as a resource
in this piece of Journalism drew a
fogelio
I haven't had anything good to say about
her in the past to be honest with you
and uh
linking to that stuff is pretty
disappointing it says uh read men in
their living rooms with microphones was
the hyperlink uh that are prompting
women to mock them and beg them to stop
giving men microphones
um that was a very reasonable snippet
with Iman in it I don't know too much
about him from what I've seen online
he's a successful 23 year old
entrepreneur good for him
um he's being criticized by an obese
walking red flag essentially you go
through my red flag chapter and I would
imagine you'd find at least a dozen on
this uh tick tocker Drew
prompting the mock okay let's wrap this
up essence of girls United with Kenyatta
Victoria this week pointed out that
everyone seems to have a podcast these
days what was once a space where people
could report and speak on specific
topics with experts has become an
opportunity for someone to project their
emotions and opinions that don't evolve
them Victoria wrote urging viewers to
amplify those who approach the craft
ethically and responsibly rather than
constantly fueling the ego I would agree
with this line over here approach the
craft of podcasting ethically and
responsibly rather than constantly
fueling the ego
fueling confirmation biases fueling egos
look I've already covered enough out of
that article I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out